now it's far from clear that the Prime
Minister can get Brussels to agree to a
new brexit deal but if he does he's
going to need MPs from the opposition
benches to help get it through
Parliament MPs like Labour's at least an
Andy who joins us now from Wigan thank
you very much for being on the program
so if Boris Johnson can get a deal with
the EU which of course is a big if could
you support it well I could support a
deal I would support a deal the problem
is at the moment that we don't have a
deal what we've got is a proposal which
stands virtually no chance of being
accepted by the EU which creates two
borders on the island of Ireland which
has is completely incompatible with
existing international law and which
rips up the workers rights and
protections and the environmental
protections that we spent several months
at the start of this year negotiating
with the former Prime Minister I would
vote for a deal but this is not a deal
this is a pre-election party political
broadcast from the Prime Minister and
the truth is that for all of the talk
about getting brexit done were further
away from achieving a deal than we were
two months ago when it became prime
minister so even if the EU signs off
these proposals which I admit dusting
quite unlikely in a minute you wouldn't
pay for anyway well one of the major
problems with these proposals is what it
potentially does to Northern Ireland the
Prime Minister has told us that it
doesn't create there'll be no new
infrastructure but he's proposing a
border away from the border which will
rely on infrastructure he hasn't been
able to explain at all how it won't and
so it puts the Good Friday Agreement at
serious risk the only way in which you
could get that through is to get the EU
to agree to it not just the EU but
actually because he'll need an opt-out
from international law from the Komet
common transit convention he'll have to
get countries like Norway Switzerland
Turkey to agree to it this was already
rejected back in 2018 and the UK is a co
guarantor of the Good Friday Agreement
it's just quite simply not a responsible
thing to propose it sounds virtually no
chance of being accepted I certainly
wouldn't vote for something that would
tear up the Good Friday Agreement you
see some people listening to it me
feel that we'd be marched off this hill
before you know Labour MP saying that
they do want a deal they do want to
leave with a deal they don't want a
second referendum they don't want no
deal but then when push comes to shove
they back away and they don't follow
through with this idea that they are
prepared to vote for a deal I mean how
many Labour MPs do you think are serious
about trying to get brexit over the line
well I think there are a lot of Labour
MPs there are about 40 still who have
been working cross-party for the last
three years trying to find a way to
achieve a deal and there are still
discussions going on there's a
cross-party group MPs for a deal we've
had some limited conversations with
senior members of Boris Johnson's
government about what would be
acceptable and how we might achieve that
and it's time for all political parties
to get serious now really we had two and
a half years of negotiations within the
Tory party this was always going to be
something that had to be agreed cross
party because of the divisions that
exists in the country we then had four
months of negotiations with Theresa Mays
government which resulted in a
withdrawal agreement bill which should
have found broad cross-party support but
then the Prime Minister resigned and it
never came before the house now there
are many of us who are currently working
to see if there's a way that we can
bring that bill before the House for the
first time and make sure that we can
agree that deal if we're serious about
preventing no deal that is the only way
to do it but Therese made did bring
proposals to the House of Commons before
do you regret not supporting them well
she brought a proposal to leave the EU
three times but with no guarantee at all
about where we were going you know I'm
sitting here in my hometown of Wigan
where we have huge numbers of food
manufacturing jobs 15,000 people work in
the food manufacturing industry many of
them in small and medium companies that
rely on those workers rights protections
level playing fields access to the
customs union and the single market all
of those things really really matter in
this town it took us months to get that
prime minister to understand that those
things had to be guaranteed before
labour
Pease could vote to leave the European
Union she did finally understand that
but this new Prime Minister seems not to
understand that and it's deeply
frustrating that for all of this talk
about getting brexit done he doesn't
seem to be serious at all about trying
to agree a cross-party deal and move us
forwards you mentioned about earlier in
the interview that you've been having
some conversations with members of Boris
Johnson's team what are we talking to
and what what are you been saying so I
haven't personally had any conversations
at so far but there have been some
attempts to talk cross-party with senior
members of the cabinet and I know that
there are other Labour MPs who've been
approached and have had some of those
conversations so far the the cross party
talks the cross party work that is going
on is much more between back benches of
all parties who are currently trying to
see if there's a way that we could bring
the withdrawal agreement bill before the
house that was a bill that came out of
the cross party talks it met the vast
majority of Labour's key tests and it's
the way the only way in my view to
prevent us leaving with no deal in just
a few weeks time do you think it's
strange that members of Boris Johnson's
team haven't reached out personally to
you given that you have been saying
pretty consistently over the last year
or so that you would be prepared to vote
for a deal if you think it's the right
one well I think there are people in
this existing government who are serious
about trying to agree a deal but I think
that what we've seen from the Prime
Minister over the last two months since
he was made prime minister by the Tory
party is much more about electioneering
much less about trying to resolve what
is a national crisis from the word go
he's alienated those MPs that he would
need to rely on to get a deal some of
the language that is used in the House
of Commons the references to my
colleague Joe Cox have really really
upset and offended many people who he
would need to vote for this deal I still
believe that it's important that we do
work cross-party to get those guarantees
and to get that deal through but he's
not behaving like a prime minister who's
at all serious this is about an
impending
general election and Boris Johnson
trying to go to the country pretending
that he's trying to get brexit done but
in reality all he's doing is wasting
time and running down the clock as we
approach No Deal just mentioning that
election there and which most people
agree is probably gonna happen sooner
rather than later and how did that
election labour are engaging in some
reasons we've seen for example the
Labour MPs Dame Margaret Hodge we've
seen Donna Johnson facing force election
battles Louise Elmen is also facing a
confidence vote what do you make of all
this is this really sending out the
right message about labour unity ahead
of an election I think it's obviously
important that we we always go through
Rhys elections I'm going through mine
now and we always go back to our party
members and ask for their support again
to stand a forthcoming general election
and I think that accountability and that
level of democracy in the party really
matters I think what is problematic
about the process that we're currently
going through though is that we've seen
a number of MPs targeted and plunged
into a full open selection process with
a general election just weeks away and
to the outside world to the public that
just looks like labour fighting with
itself rather than providing a unified
force that is capable of going out and
talking to the country and you can see
that reflected in the opinion polls I
think it's not the only reason that both
labour and the Tories are suffering in
the opinion polls I think our inability
to compromise and to find a way through
what has become a national crisis is
part of the story you know when I was
knocking on doors in Wigan six months
ago people were very very angry with us
with all political parties for not
compromising now I just get a very
strong sense that people have completely
stopped listening and to a certain
extent what we say now matters much less
than what we do we've got to compromise
we've got to work cross party and we've
got to find a way to leave with a deal
that protects people's jobs in towns
like this okay listen Andy thank you
very much for being on the program today
thank you